maybe we can start at the very beginning
uh what were your first impressions of
each other well we should tell the story
that how you met yeah
i'll set it up and then jeff you can
take it away to take people way back
when in the wayback machine
david letterman announces he's
because he didn't get the tonight show
he's pissed he's angry he feels like
that he was in line for that
jay got it forget his last name and
so letterman's upset and then he does
the thing that nbc doesn't see coming he
says i'm out of here yeah and they never
thought he would do that and so suddenly
uh there's an opening
they need a host for 12 30
and in a streaming era all there are
there's no such thing as a time slot
anyway really but there's just an
infinite number of jobs now and shows
back then when there was a space
available it was
like a once in a decade event especially
in late night it was a big deal it was a
huge deal and everyone's like who's
going to replace dave and what they the
affiliates
were getting nervous so nbc had an idea
which is to stall
and to keep the affiliates calm we'll
just tell them lorne michaels is going
to figure it out the
you know producers are not live and he
always makes the right choice so lauren
will do it and so lauren agreed to that
i think you know and with the
understanding that he would produce it
and that bought nbc some time with the
affiliates they're like whoa oh good
good well then lauren is figuring it out
it's being handled it's being handled
and so then and that's great shorthanded
getting put out it was a very good idea
on um and nbc has only had good ideas
this was an incredible team a brain
trust and then they um
so lauren's handling it and then
lauren's first move
before he picks anybody is he knows
a young lad named jeff ross
and he dials the phone jeff
fresh back from cabo even back then
tequila getting abused no no no not at
all and by the way this is a six hour
episode it's more like a recta rectal
exam yeah
it won't be that pleasant yeah yeah
those who get medication from mexico i
love a rectal exam if i get the wrong
profile
so
phone rings and jeff you take it from
there uh i'm leaving lauren
i get that lauren says to me i guess it
was in the news we all knew he was gonna
produce the show and pick the host and
he says to me would would you produce it
how did you know lauren oh i'm sorry
that's true that's a good thing here
yeah that's called a follow-up question
i had spent a year in canada producing
the kids in the hall and then i was
doing some other shows for lauren a lot
of hbo specials and
i was around and lorne knew me and i
guess he just
he had to hire somebody to do something
on this thing so he he called me and he
was like so you know i'm doing this
thing i got the i got to find the i got
to produce the show to replace letterman
i go i heard
and he says you want to produce it and
it it's it's sort of to what kind of was
saying it's such a surreal
thing you know let alone you know
obviously
you want to be the host somebody says
you want to produce the show that that's
going to replace letterman which was the
biggest thing at the time
and there's no idea who the host is so i
wound up in this
sort of like crazy whirlwind of
nutty
ideas and going to auditions i think at
the same time he was talking to you he
talked to you first because i knew i had
heard your name
we hadn't met yet we hadn't met and and
lauren i had left
snl
and
two two years earlier maybe two and a
half years earlier and gone to the
simpsons right yeah and uh so i was in
los angeles and i had moved on lauren
very sweetly had really wanted me to
stay at snl and he was saying you can
work from home it was really nice
he really was he said he said there's
going to be a terrible virus
there's a there's a virus in wuhan
there's
no scene
and i said no i really have to go i was
going through a lot at the time it'll
all be in my memoir i was going through
a lot of stuff uh in my personal life
and
i was i think very unhappy and i just
decided i've gotta
leave uh
the east coast and so i i got this great
chance to work on the simpsons so i'm
there and i really feel like i've put
new york in my rearview mirror and i've
put even though i had an amazing
experience at snl i thought that's all
behind me now and then it's now two
years later and the phone rings and it's
lorne and um
he
said that he's setting up the new late
night should replace letterman and i'll
remember very clearly me saying whoa
good luck because there's no replacing
letterman
and i was just sorry for whoever gets no
no i i really need to show a test
pattern and i think jeff probably felt
the same way we both felt like i mean he
had been
you know dave had
you know recreated
um
the talk show and and
and created this whole new sensibility
and it felt like he had discovered this
whole new continent and how do you
follow that and he had carved out 1235
as this yes and i actually thought it
wasn't really going to happen you
thought what i just thought it wasn't
going to happen what do you mean in
other words either lauren wasn't going
to produce it or you know some something
was going to happen and i wasn't going
to produce it right so it just seemed
not real were you at the time did you
hesitate to say yes to producing this
show no i said yes you just jumped right
in yeah okay i said yeah a lot of crazy
but i hadn't but i i didn't believe it
okay okay and i and and so lauren at
first is talking to me about being um
the
kind of head writer right so jeff will
be the producer who makes it all happen
and then i'll be the the head writer
sort of producer
and i remember
initially being like well i'll talk to
you about it i had it first of all i had
a
contract at the simpsons right that
technically wasn't breakable which
sounds crazy but box is hard they don't
i'm not kidding they they
and so i think they're on the story yeah
i had signed like a a four-year deal
to be at the simpsons and i think i was
doing a good job and they liked having
me there so
um this is not a place
uh not the simpsons and be specific here
fox is not a place where you can just
say you know what right i'm out of here
yeah and i also kept saying i don't
think anyone can replace letterman i
mean i was saying that uh and thinking
that and
actually still believe it
i see no evidence no i'm i'm not kidding
i still think that's the case
but we hadn't met yet right jeff's just
a name and then i bow out i say you know
what i remember having an anxiety attack
a really strong anxiety attack right and
thinking i just can't do this i actually
went and met lauren who had an office at
the time at the paramount lot and i just
said i can't do it and he was i think a
little rattled because he i think was
telling people i've got this lined up
i've got jeff i've got conan he's trying
to put pieces together he's trying to
put the piece against an anxiety attack
just on being the head writer of the
show yeah and you don't know who the
host is and i don't know who the host is
and so i
bow out and so i'm out of the process
and i remember feeling a huge sense of
relief huge relief yeah
then a couple of weeks go by and lauren
i think had a showcase and i think jeff
went to the showcase i was on the east
coast doing another show
and i had to go come to la to do a
different show
and lauren calls me to his office the
same office at paramount so i go see him
and he says you're still going to prove
the show right the late night show
and i went
yeah yeah but but do you know who the
host is says well can you go to this
showcase tonight at the improv uh-huh
and we've talked about this before yeah
yeah it's like you know yeah there's
like
five comics all male 1
and they all knew that they were
auditioning for lauren oh yeah oh yeah
the lord was there and so was and so
were the guys who wrote the network don
allmeyer was there uh warren littlefield
was there but johnny golia was there he
was like the business affairs guy and
afterwards what was that what was the
rest those guys are always good laughs
remember the mustache oh yeah remember
the mustache cafe biz affairs the
mustache counter that was across from
the remember the mustache so afterwards
they're all going us and lauren goes
come on come with us and i'm thinking
this is
it's crazy yeah and we go over there and
i'm sitting there and he goes and
everybody's arguing about who they
thought was good and who was not good
and and oh my gosh everybody meet my
office tomorrow and lauren times me goes
can you come to this meeting at o'myer's
office and i go sure
and so i go to this office and this is
when
the connection started
with conan oh myers kind of beating up
on everybody
because that's kind of the way he was
you know yeah he was uh donald meyer
you all know him but he was running nbc
when uh the oj trial was happening and
don was very good friends with oj and um
would get very upset when norm mcdonald
would do jokes that basically said for
reasons i don't because i don't see the
evidence but
basically
basically say that on the day of the
verdict nor macdonald said well it's
official murder is now legal in the
state of california but john olamir was
kind of like imagine
babe ruth
45 years old like a big over the top and
i have a lot of affection for don i want
to make that clear i really do and i
think he had a lot of really good
qualities and he was very loyal to me in
the long run so there's a lot of things
about don that i'm i have very good
feelings about but he was he could
sometimes
he could be very intimidating and be
kind of he had a sports mentality
because he had come from the world of
sports so it was a lot of like kicking
guys in the ass and get out there come
on you got to figure it out get your
head in the game you [ __ ] and it was
that kind of absolutely so finally
lauren says well i think conan could do
it
and he turns to me and says don't you
think
oh wow and that was the first time he
brought it up he had not met
he had never met me until i
smartly go yeah i think so
and i'll never forget this and and then
and then omar goes well can we test them
and then lauren turns to me and goes can
we test them
and i go yeah sure
so what happens is i'm working at the
simpsons like
a normal everyday joe and i come home
with my lunch pail and my hard hat and i
put it down and i see that there's a
machine
the machine that's back when you had a
machine with a blank spline
machine yeah and um so i play it and
it's and it's not lauren doesn't leave
messages to this day but it's one of his
35 people saying um conan could give
lauren a call so i called him and he
said look i know you don't want to do it
but would you be interested in going to
an audition now i had a panic attack at
that which is the idea that i would
audition because i was a writer now
things have changed a lot since then
this is
before
i mean now
seth meyers john mulaney there's just
this long tradition tina fey
people are writers and then um
they they get elevated uh and and they
figure it out
this
hadn't really happened before right now
behind the scenes i had been kind of a
performing writer for a bunch of years
doing improv
groundlings and improvisation and and
constantly uh it's where i met lisa
kudrow doing we started doing improv in
85. and i was so i was very interested
in that right but i was not a stand-up
comic which is really was considered
it's like to drive a car you need a
license yes what do you mean you're not
a stand-up comic so i was just a guy
that
was a mindset back then yeah and i
remembered at snl
i was jim downey was always putting me
in things because i was the guy who was
in the room
entertaining the room
of writers yeah
in a room full of writers my and to this
day my favorite place to be is in a room
full of writers
yeah trying to make everybody laugh and
doing a dance for them or spitting out
some wild thread and so i think lauren
had seen me doing that right he had seen
me cracking up jim downey and he had
seen me you know play little utility
roles and sketches here and there right
and so
the notion was
maybe so he talks to me
i'm very nervous
i call robert smeigle imagine yeah
robert smeigle's
response
was you know i wouldn't do it if i were
you oh wow now listen listen i'm going
to say that's for your own sake i'm
assuming no no but listen he to be
honest he was echoing everything in my
head yeah yeah it's what everyone would
say yeah he said i wouldn't do it if i
were you
and i said and what's the reason and he
said
because that is a hard way to get into
show business like
you're a complete unknown
the knives will be out he said all the
things that ended up uh to a large
degree playing out and he was telling me
all that and i was nodding i remember
uh this was a apartment on cochrane
um cochran near the grove
no i'm sorry hold that no i'm sorry no
not cochran that was my earlier
apartment i moved around more than like
ted bundy bundy drive yeah bundy once
said to me before he was executed you
moved around a lot and i'm like you know
what
that's my business but i was on
weatherly which is kind of near the four
seasons hotel so i had this little like
i was a guy that didn't know how to
furnish an apartment
i just
wrote and ate out at chinese food places
at night and worked on my simpson
scripts you know completely undeveloped
uh male human and i was in this little
breakfast nook and i remember very
clearly the table i was sitting at
talking on this shitty little phone
and robert saying i don't think i would
do it i was like kind of agreeing in the
background i heard michelle
his wife
say uh who's fantastic and michelle i
just heard her in the background go
william
i couldn't quite hear her and i said
what did she say and i heard robert talk
to her and then he came back to the
phone and he went well michelle says
what do you have to lose
and then i heard in the background
michelle was like he should do it what
does he have to lose he's funny and i
had this little like tremor of
maybe yeah what do i have to lose and
then robert went well that's a really
good point so
i thought well what's the worst that
could happen if i audition i'm not to
get it but i'm interested in this
getting out in front of people
so that's when the next thing i know i'm
told by lauren okay
we're going to test you
you're to go meet jeff ross at the four
seasons hotel which in in beverly hills
which was like a five-minute walk from
my apartment so i walk over
i get to the lobby first because jeff's
up upstairs
beauty regimen
putting the cucumbers on his eyes he
needed a spa hotel and he's charged and
i'm downstairs and there's a lobby
they've changed the lobby of the four
seasons now
but there used to be this um kind of
business desk that was made of lucite it
was like a clear plastic desk when i
went and i was sitting at that clear
plastic desk just waiting and then jeff
comes off the elevator we've never met
and he walks around the corner and goes
and i go
uh jeff goes conan and i go jeff and i
go yeah and then i gesture to the desk
and go what do you think
like true i could
yeah i kind of hit i kind of hit the
desk and like what do you think and jeff
was like no lose sight and jeff
pierre jeff was like
i don't know
and i was like yeah i know so then we
talked about how crazy it was honestly
chemistry was off the charts yeah right
away right away you know what i love my
first interaction with jeff was
disinterest right
and no faith in me and nothing's changed
he would have been looking at his cell
phone if he'd had one there was no cell
phone no jeff used to carry a rotary
phone
jeff
you couldn't really believe in your
heart it was going to happen like you
were probably both laughing at them yes
when you met each other right it was
completely absurd
and i have to say you're crazy i was
laughing at that point because
i took what michelle
uh robert's wife said his heart which is
oh what the [ __ ] just try this it's not
going to happen anyway right so
it's a good experience
this story i mean this story could be a
whole
we could do nine hours on this story and
i'm trying to move it along but
long story short
jeff starts to with nbc's help starts to
put together kind of like an audition
and the only space they have to use is
the tonight show um
and trust me it's always been good luck
for me
so uh they set up um the idea is when
jay's done with his show he's gonna
leave and the crowd's gonna leave
they're gonna bring in another audience
and
the idea was i will come out and do a
monologue
and then interview two
celebrities and i won't know who they
are until i get to burbank wow so jeff
was putting it together and trying to
find the celebrities
and i had nothing to wear
so at the time i call
my best friend lisa kudrow and i say
lisa you've got to help me and she says
don't worry i can help you so she took
me to makeover montage well it's
hilarious this is the worst makeover
montage but i had no one he would just
two two thirds of the way through the
movie that's when they went to best buy
and
no uh we went to fred siegel oh down
here santa monica i have a 1992 ford
taurus with a stick shift
very proud of that we still have by the
way it's you know what i can't believe
it is
it's still on our budget oh like of the
thanksgiving
when you sign the chat i don't want it
that's uh it's
no but i mean it's paid off by now isn't
it no no no
it could be you could make it an airbnb
so you could be earning money
so i
pick up lisa we drive over to fred
siegel and we go to
we're walking around now i now know
things just from being in show business
but i kind of know like i should
probably they should put some makeup on
me yeah but i also know kind of when
you're my coloring what are good colors
to wear like blues are really good they
make the old blue eyes pop
and they also um what colors really help
if you are very very pale redhead
the one thing i've learned that you're
not supposed to do is wear
very very pale like white
i should not wear that so lisa
and i together we committed this crime
together
like leopold and low
individually we would not have killed
but together we did
we pick out a white linen jacket
a white linen jacket like a white shirt
i think and i throw in the back of my
ford taurus which by the way i later
found out has radiator fluid
in the back green radiator fluid which
got on some part of the jacket but i
that i hid i love that
ford taurus was the car you drove to to
do that so then jeff sets this thing up
and we're kind of talking back and forth
yeah then i drive it's set up for this
time i drive to burbank i get there and
when i get there
you guys had worked it out you had found
mimi rogers
and jason alexander
as guests as guests and jason alexander
of course uh doing uh
seinfeld and uh mimi rogers was doing
movies and she had been a model and
modeled and you know and married tom
cruise yeah uh brief marriage to tom
cruise yeah
my first time getting interview notes so
i got research you jeff had arranged he
asked nbc and they said yeah we can use
the tonight show research so i was given
a research that they had on file for the
last time jason alexander had been on
the tonight show and the last time you
meet uh rogers have been on the tonight
show so i go in this office and i'm just
looking and i'm scribbling out my
monologue which i had been thinking
about
yeah i had no writers
oh my god how far in advance of the
tapings was this
hold on what what is that what's that
says
there's a
vikings are landing
he didn't mute us
it was like a horn it was like yeah
it was a norse horse it is so i want to
use that ringtone i'm in the north if
you see the movie i interrupt a tribal
retreat with my phone
so please check out the doors please
keep that in so
i like these are the best moments
mike sweeney's phone just went off and
his ringtone is a norse
norse horns
the tonight show was still going on when
i got there they were still taping it
which might be maybe they taped it i
don't know five to six or something
right and so this would have been after
that i think our taping was going to
start at seven okay like that i'm going
over the notes i had come up with an
idea for a monologue it wasn't topical
yeah uh which would
sort of foretell the kind of comedy
right but it was all about the absurdity
of me um and i remember the monologue
was kind of i think actually you can see
it now but um
i think i was very taken with i need to
get this job quickly
because the irish don't age well and
it's it's a theme i've been working a
lot just gonna say holy cow and i was
like and i was like my face is
acceptable for television now but as ted
kennedy is proof that my face is going
to expand and so i had this whole and
then that's what i remember most is
then it's time to do it it's really
surreal jeff's over at the you know at
the podium
and we go
there's no band or anything and i come
out and i was immediately
surprisingly comfortable i was just very
i like i had always liked being on stage
i was very comfortable doing the
monologue and then i slid over and the
minute i got behind the desk i was just
kind of happy
and
mimi rogers came out first
and the and the jason alexander was
second i don't know if you remember this
but in between the two it was like a
commercial break like a fake commercial
what happened in a script packet i guess
it was the research or something yeah i
don't know if you remember this i wrote
on that and i just scribbled on the back
you're killing yeah and they slid it in
front of him and what he did was he and
he looked yeah he should have fixed his
thigh or something yeah yeah you know
he's still here
no we shredded everything immediately
right right jeff wanted we were like
we were like the germans as the russians
were just shredding and burning
everything um
but
yes i remember that very clearly and
what i remember is the monologue went
well and i just felt comfortable doing
it it was very me yeah i wasn't trying
to like tell jokes about clinton or tell
i was just and you're doing great ice
breaking for that audience to like yeah
you knew that they didn't know who you
were well also to let them overcome the
shock of this is a very pale man wearing
a white linen jacket
with uh radiator stains on the back
but then i cross over and i talk to mimi
rogers
and what i remember was there was a
moment which
if you look at late night moments since
or whatever you'd think well this isn't
that
it was fine right but
what happened was you got to see kind of
for a second i think
economy i was my very myself right so
mimi rogers is talking and i'm
interviewing her my posture's terrible
my hair's all droopy i'm wearing this
awful jacket i'm listening to her and
then she said uh
she said yeah you know people i'd model
and she said and a lot of people say
modeling is easy but it's a tough job
and i was being polite and agreeing
going yeah yeah yeah no i can see i can
see and then i just stop myself and i go
wait a minute no no i'm sorry i'm sorry
a tough job is like turning a big crank
right right and i mind turning a big
crank that's a tough job turning a big
crank and people laughed and it was very
spontaneous
and we do this
and the jason alexander went well but
that was a moment of me just
interrupting and then almost acting out
a cartoon image
and inserting my personality into the
situation and then it ended
and i went with i think lisa and i went
to man i wish i could um it's a woman
it's actually it's a fred seagull yeah
we went back to set shield just turn the
channel to sue them and we put the
jacket back on the shelf
and i said yeah yeah i can't it came
like that
there were cell phones then because i
remember driving away you would they
were huge
yeah and i was in the car and lauren
calls me and says that went well and i
went oh yeah because he was watching in
new york and he goes but it's going to
be shadowing
yeah all right
so right away now this is what i kind of
knew yeah so that they were talking so i
had done this thing and this thing
i have to say the audition made me
really want to do it because i thought
yeah i was like a duck that had never
been put in water
and suddenly i was like oh that felt
right that and i'm not used to feeling
good about anything and it'll only go
well yeah exactly it'll only go that
well but you had a total flip where
you're like now i want well
i was excited but i couldn't even let
myself think that yet so i was excited
but i couldn't get myself to that point
yet but i remember we went out to kate
mantellini remember kate mantellini that
restaurant that's on wilshire i went
there with lisa and everyone was really
excited and then i was 29 at the time
and my 30th birthday was about a week
and a half away i remember that yeah wow
so then when my 30th i'd go back to the
simpsons and it was just well get back
to work yeah
and then i had a conversation
a couple days later lauren called me
and i was in my car so you're right
there were giant car phones but you know
yeah i was in my car and lauren called
me he loves to break bad news on over a
phone in a car
and he told me you were great
yeah and he said i'll never forget he
said bob wright
um loved your interview and he loved the
whole crank thing when you did the crank
thing he loved that
and i remember thinking it's true it
could be the train no no i said what i
was gonna say is who the [ __ ] is bob
right i don't know who bob wright is i
didn't know who bob wright was and they
said well and he said bob wright loves
it and suzanne really loves it and i
said well who were they and he and and
lauren was like what are you talking
about
he's the president of around the network
he ran the network of nbc and he and his
wife they they expressed them
this videotape out in connecticut and
they watched it and they're like we like
this weird irish kid with the funny name
yeah that crank thing man that really
cracked us up
but then he called me later on and said
you know the same thing that he had told
jeff he said look it's not going to be
you you're not going to get
12 30. but you did yourself a lot of
good and they're probably going to give
you like 130 and i remember thinking
well that would be great because
there's no pressure right
if i get 130 there's no pressure
and wait a minute that's that's cool
mm-hmm and i'll never forget you started
wanting that yeah yeah i still want 130.
uh i'll take that now
i'll give it to you but i hung up the
phone
when i was with lisa and lisa was like
well that's you know so you're not going
to get 12 30 and i said
uh i don't know if i don't think this
channel is going to happen
and she said well lauren just told you
what's going to happen and i said i
don't know why but i just said
it doesn't make sense to me
gary is a peer of dave's
and he's killing it with his own show
larry sanders yeah and he's getting all
of his critical acclaim and awards for
making fun of the forum right who wants
to go in and go in every day and try and
do it yeah and i said i just it's not
going to be shambling i don't think
shane's going to do it i think that's
that doesn't make any sense to me he's
too cautious he's too
smart he's not going to no he's not
going to want to go in every day and
figure this out and sure enough that's
what ended up happening yeah i think i
told the story but i was i don't know
what i talked to you guys last time but
i was basically in my i was out for
lunch or something i had an office of
broadway video in new york and i come
back and i had all these messages
when they used to be like
paper messages that you would paint yeah
and they were all people that had
something to do with it it was just
obvious i was like right hello [ __ ] he
got it oh wow and how long was just a
couple of weeks after what was it well i
remember
one of the last things i remember from
the old life
the um
black and white the black and white
portion of wizard of oz
before i open the cabin door what i
remember really well is i had a birthday
party was when i turned 30.
and i had it at my apartment on
weatherly and
a second floor a par apartment on the
second floor was a sort of a duplex old
1920s place
and
all my friends at the simpsons and my
writer friends came over and everyone
brought gag gifts
like someone brought me uh arsenio's
like had written a book like his bite
you know and and people they all knew
that you were in this process
yeah you know everyone knew that i was
in this process and everyone was talking
about it but it was kind of funny yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah you know well here's
your how-to book
and everybody
and and um jeff
was there and we had this nice birthday
party which was april 18th
1993. and then it was a i was like see
ya it was like see you go back to new
york yeah jeff's going back to new york
and i'm get back with my get on with my
life
and it's in the back of my mind that
something might happen but i don't know
what right
and it may have been a week later
i'm in a record at the simpsons
it was in the basement in the building
on the fox slot
and the way you do a record is there's a
table read first so the whole cast is
there and we go through the script
and then it's done and everyone applauds
and then what happens is we quickly talk
about
what changes may need to be made before
they start doing the record and the
writers are all going to work that out
make these changes as they're recording
to try and tighten it up just a little
more and i remember we had just finished
and we're starting to talk about it when
there's a phone call someone in the room
said conan the phone's for you
and i picked it up and i put the phone
to my ear and it's gavin pallone who's
still my manager i've been with him
forever he said
you got 12 30.
and and i said this not in a celebratory
way i said it in a defeated way he said
you got 12 30 and i went
i know
because i just had this you had a
premonition i just knew for some [ __ ]
reason
and so i didn't want it i
leave the room i walk up the stairs i
walk outside and i was told by gavin i
said i know and then he said uh donald
mayor is calling you in like five
minutes in your office and i hung up
and i start walking and then i start
going into a slight it's very cinematic
but i start walking fast then i start
running right and i run to my office
and then he's saying okay here's the
plan
you got it kid i think it's all crazy
but you got it now here's the idea
he said you're going on a tonight show
tonight because i'm sick of us getting
scooped what they've scooped us the
whole time and we're gonna show we're
gonna flip the script on the media he
had this very like combative sporty yeah
so he said jay's gonna just say we got
the new host for the for the late night
show here he is and you're gonna walk
out there and you're just gonna and he
said kick it in the balls you know and
really show who's who and i'm just the
kid that just came out of a record yeah
and i'm like um oh and he's like shut up
get in your car and get over to nbc
right now before the press finds out so
the next thing i know i'm driving over
to and i'm in a totally oh no
panic and then they sure enough
uh jay calls me out and remembered
robert and i think this is good robert
was like don't take any big swings right
you know because the worst thing that i
could do is going i was kidding yeah
yeah she was like you do you do you have
a lot to lose
the simpsons is a good gig so what
robert said no no he was just like don't
take any big swings and i remember
thinking yeah yeah because if they say
hey guess what we found a new
replacement for letterman his name's uh
chip quizly and uh here he is and you
walk out there and go hey everybody
knock knock who's there
an elephant an elephant who i don't know
i forgot my trunk
hello
i just played it straight like i and i
remembered uh people were like well if
that's the new host of late night
and i was like you know he didn't come
out and kill and i think oh meyer really
wanted me to go out there and say like
all right everybody now listen to this
you know and we're that's right do the
incredibly smart yeah so and he told don
i'm gonna bring that to the show don't
worry
more of that and at that point all went
very smoothly yeah well jeff we're so
you that i was not there oh you were
back in new york yeah
i did did you guys talk before he went
on jay i don't think we probably don't
think so okay i'm not sure if we did it
all right so then what happened
next with you two we had to figure out
how to make a show and uh conan got came
in back to new york
got a place i had to well the crazy
thing is i had to go
they wanted to introduce me to the press
in the rainbow room
that was the first big hurdle was i had
to immediately come east it was not
clear because then nbc started to get
into it with fox and fox was like excuse
me he's under contract i i can't believe
yeah and we were like well this one in a
billion year accident just happened
where one of your writers is going to
get to again i want to be clear it was
not the simpsons the simpsons were
really great about it but there was an
executive at fox who was saying no i
don't know so uh nbc and i i think had i
think
i had to pay money and nbc had to pay
money to get me out of my contract
that's crazy because at the time these
shows were making so much money right
they were nickel and diming every little
thing yeah
that's how they made it they weren't
happy for you you had a line at the
press conference yes what was it you
know we all met it was going to be in
the rainbow room which is the top of
rockford center and everyone from the
press corps was going to be there and i
was going to
go out and
meet the press
and we all met at lauren's apartment and
the nbc people were there and then we
walked through the park it is now early
may we're walking through the park
and i'm seeing rock forest center get
closer and closer and closer and i know
that i have to go to the top of this
tower and then meet
the nastiest press yeah in the history
of media this is cinematic as well yeah
and so we're walking there and then as
we are getting to 30 rock trying to keep
it light and trying to stay loose a
reporter comes up to me says i forget if
he said he was from the post or newsweek
but he said hey conan my job is i was at
letterman's letterman had had a press
conference for his new cbs show at radio
city like the week before and of course
being you know he killed destroyed right
he said i was at letterman's press
conference last week and i know how many
laughs he got on my job is to count how
many laughs you get and see how you
stack up and
he told me that as we were going through
the i mean on the north side it should
be illegal right in between radio city
and rockford center we were going in
right there and he was like my job's to
count how many laughs
you know so it was literally like good
luck spartacus in the ring
so i go up there lauren talks briefly
and there's a shot i mean
vanity fair covered it at the time and
there's a great
the iconic photographer uh anyway
lewis took a shot of me a reverse shot
i'm in the front and it's the entire
press corps and explosion of photographs
and i'm
as i said i'm a week and a half earlier
i was uh in the room at the simpsons
right yeah it's still not real no but i
remember that the thing that saved my
ass was i get up to the microphone
i remember and stuttering john from the
howard stern show was there and he's
wearing a terrible fake mustache and
fake glasses on like a wig
and so he goes like conan conan who did
you have to sleep with to get this job
and i just just said uh no one i wasn't
sleeping with before next question and
everybody laughed
and then i was like hey hey that's
stuttering john john take off the wig
because he kept his job was to [ __ ] with
me yeah yeah yeah and i was loving it
anytime he'd say something i'd be like i
would have fun with it and then i was
like john come on take off the end and
end that wasn't there uh somebody said
to you something about being a relative
unknown no no you're uh
yeah aren't you a relative unknown i
said sir i am a complete unknown and
then people were like
that's jesus i remember foolishly the
press conference went really well and
the take was well he's funny and it
could work that's and all you wanted he
got three laughs he got three laps right
i'm dying to hear that
count i want to take up that art but you
did a thing i'm sorry john
that you've done every time since i
think where you have an event is
is like if you can find one person
mm-hmm
a true line and to play off of and
you've always been graded i always try
and find who's going to be my first
right yeah and then use them as the
through line and stuttering john was
there and he was my foil and to make
things even crazier that event's over
and the first thing i hear is um bob
wright of we love the crank
bob right
bob wright's having a
uh 50th birthday party in connecticut
and they want you to go up and be the
one of the one of the people
no one of the people who speaks and it's
in three days and i said okay
so i come up with an idea for what i
could do
and i worked on it with robert i get in
a uh
town car with lauren because he's coming
too
and we drive out to this nice part of
connecticut
and we walk into this very fancy country
club where there's a big party and i
recognize all these famous people you
know there's all these people from the
today show and all these people from all
the different nbc shows are there to
salute bob brennan's 50th
and my job is to get up and speak
and i and i get there and um who's
standing ramrod straight in the corner
but johnny carson
oh my god and john and i am the opener
this guy can't catch a break i am the
opener for johnny carson and my previous
experience is uh
i did some i did some pretty good improv
at the groundlings and um had thought of
one good quip with uh mimi rogers
and so he's standing there and he's
wearing sunglasses inside i remember and
he just looked it's johnny carson it's
the biggest thing
and suddenly i'm being introduced to him
and i said well i called him mr carson
and he went please uh call me johnny and
i went oh johnny and he was very he
seemed kind of quiet and reserved so i
didn't say that much to him
and then i got up
and
uh i think the idea that i went with was
giving a toast about someone i clearly
don't know
so i was like what can i tell you about
bob wright and it was all the jokes were
things like he's i think five nine right
he is the and it's clear i've just
looked stuff up on wikipedia uh which
actually didn't exist didn't exist um in
encyclopedia yeah anyway i had that
experience and then he like applauded
and gave like a little like good for you
kind of yeah that was okay it was fine
and um
yeah there was no prank
and he said follow that car yeah i've i
should have totally i should have
totally been like now [ __ ] johnny
coach
but then he got up and of course um blew
the lid off the place uh but
that was how rapidly insane things were
happening you know it was like rainbow
room meet the new york press and be
confronted by stuttering john off to
open for johnny carson and it was just
this cavalcade of craziness i remember
and then it was go meet all the
affiliates i had to go like around the
united states and meet affiliates that
seems at least like
i don't know that seems like a
cool down period compared to what you
just described the one point i would
make
that i am still blown away by is that
this process of
bullshittery that had to happen of
things that needed to happen you know um
press and affiliates and
um birthday parties and by the time
that's over
it's
late may early june and our start date
was september 13th yeah
no
band uh-huh no writers
no
it's myself and jeff just no bookers
yeah no set they've completely uh taken
out the
letterman set and so there's just a 6a
is just an empty concrete rectangle
and that's the part
that never makes sense to me is
how quickly
you know
today
when i hear about someone doing a show
it's like well you'll see it in six
months you'll see it in a year and i've
got to figure the idea
that
they found the person with the least
experience yeah in the history of the
medium and
said you can really get started on june
1st right right i wasn't exactly sure
i wasn't exactly experienced at doing a
late night talk show
i've done a lot a lot of different types
of shows
in the hall but that's a totally
different pre-tape there is nothing well
there were only two or three shows of
that kind of time so you know it's no
experience so you were both learning
yeah on the job so who did you turn to
for uh i didn't really
well you know
he's probably pretty busy no
a little bit of lauren you know lauren
there was a lot of we had a lot of
saturn and live people helping us and
different different uh variations of
helping them not helping
i don't know i don't know if they were
trying to kill us or what but uh dude
that's a whole nother uh that's that
episode you realize this is nine
podcasts yeah yeah yeah
we're and we started we had this we had
that we had the stuff
i knew a lot of those people because i
had worked with them before and i we
sort of managed my way through that and
yeah it was um the process of getting a
band was insane the process of getting
built was insane there is a crazy story
behind everything and um moments
moments of true
despair i mean uh
to the point of there were i think maybe
seven different times just in that
summer
where i fantasized no joke about getting
hurt i didn't want to die like i didn't
want to but i remembered very clearly
thinking if i was hit by a car
it was very clear to me that it that
it can't be my fault but if something
were to happen to me and i'd be badly
injured i'd be off the hook right yeah
and that might be a good i would also
want an induced coma i would yes i just
would want to check
it was generous was robert morton who at
the time was producing the letter in the
show he was generous right he was a
friend of mine he was you were already
friends
he was generous about it and was there
an early moment you two remember
being thrown into this where
there was things you bonded over in
particular just we've never bonded
yeah that's what we invite this is the
first time
eight minutes ago i really started to
think this jeff ross guy there's
something to him he is like ahab my
whole thing was just try to make it as
easy as possible for
for conan right just try to keep him
away from all the [ __ ]
at that time it was kind of impossible
right because
there were a lot of
opposing forces right you know and
people who were less than helpful sure
when they were made like they were being
helpful it was just a lot of craziness
like passive aggressiveness a lot of
craziness and this is where i really
have to
i think i've tried to say this a lot in
my career and on my last tbs show and it
can't be said enough the two big things
that had to happen were
initiated and made possible by lorne so
first of all there's this weird opening
in the universe i always make fun of
marvel movies because i hate a portal
that opens in the sky
i always think it's a portal opened and
lazy lazy writing came in another
direction another dimension look uh
important but this weird portal opened
in the sky where there was a second
where
this
big tv job was kind of in play
and lorne for whatever reason and i
still maintain he may have [ __ ] up
said
conan o'brien now that's huge because
lorne was the only person in show
business
who had that power one of the people and
he's also
i think uh he's
clearly
saw something
and and said i think he could do it
probably regretted it almost immediately
and i've actually told this until when i
went back to snl a couple months ago i
said i'm sure you regretted that
immediately and he was like no but i
could tell like
fairness to lauren he did that and then
the second thing he did
was he said jeff ross
and
my dad over the years who likes to ask a
question
more than once the same question um
whatever the years go like now how did
jeff
get into the equation and i would always
say um well lauren was the one who who
brought jeff in and he would go like
well
jeff is very key and i go yes jeff's you
know
and then you know i'd count a year and a
half like now tell
he seems to compliment your energy yes
that's right dad we've talked about this
several times yeah sure this is lisa
kudrow still buying your clothes yeah
whatever happened to lisa kudrow well a
year later she did it
lauren by just moving his pinky he says
right well it's conan o'brien it's jeff
ross right yeah and i do think those are
two massive key moves and then the third
move that needed to happen at the
beginning was robert smigel
and i pushed for that and of course i
only knew robert because of snl where
i'd worked with him for all these years
and i knew that he had the sensibility
like we used to talk about this we used
to talk about comedy and i knew that
robert kind of had to be there
and lauren
you know i think was reluctant to lose
robert from snl and that was a whole
story but when you think about it the
three main players that needed to happen
for everything else to happen
really come through
top and snl and they happen
fairly quickly and then the rest is i
always think it's one of those movies
like you start with robin hood and he's
walking through the forest and then you
know he starts fighting with someone on
a stream and it's it's fryer tuck you're
with me and then you pick up people as
you go i think of it as
jeff and i pretty much start the journey
out together and robert's there almost
immediately then it's the three of us
and then it's this whole odyssey of
merry men you know literally jeff
garland saying hey check out this guy
andy richter and we do and i have lunch
with him meet him at a deli as i've said
many times and he came in and i
immediately a lot of it's instinctual
but immediately i was like this guy
needs to be part of this adventure yeah
because he's fantastic you're like
lauren all of a sudden you're just like
ah this guy those initial elements are
the fascinating part and then everything
else is right a good story and you guys
have i mean
done a great job of
mining these incredible stories because
we put together because it happened so
quickly and so strangely
we put together a group of people that
didn't know anything about tv
and
and really didn't have experience and
then we ended up you know we inherited
our crew from
letterman's old show
and he did dave did a very different
kind of show and suddenly we're telling
62 year old cameramen who've never had
to move we've got a funny idea where
conan races down sixth avenue and you
follow him and they were like how about
you go [ __ ] yourself
i'm getting on it i'll be on a break
yeah and then it was just once you hit
september 13th when we premiere
uh 93
the next two years
is us
two and a half no year and a half i
thought no i think so solid two years of
we're in terrible terrible danger of
being canceled any second we were
canceled at one point but also justified
fear because yeah there was
we were i mean you've said it you was
weak to weak for a while
all we did was
this was the way i felt is i had like
visors on i was like one of those horses
right you know what i mean you still are
very important you're still very hoarse
like
i appreciate it we give jeff a sugar
cube after after
[Laughter]
we're going to go back and retell the
whole story but you realize that this is
you just have to put your head down and
not pay attention to a lot of things
yeah go forward i mean i don't know what
you guys were expecting for length of
this podcast but it is absurd
that
i think it's just
i still to this day cannot believe
that somehow we got away with it i i
don't
100 i had one of the surreal moments
just popped into my head and one of them
was
we move in and we take over these
offices there were offices that had been
like an insurance company or something
um but they ended up being our late
night offices for all those 16 years and
we move in and there's no there's nobody
yet i mean literally there's myself and
jeff we had offices on the opposite
remember the yeah corners jeff
at least 100 feet apart but jeff jeff
had the offices that looked at the at
the sign for radio city on the north
side and i had the south side i was down
like where the writers are and jeff was
upwards you know all the adults who make
the show really work are up on that side
and i was with the idiots but at the
time there's no one's there yet people
are in the oppressive hiring people
so you could look it up but
dave winds up his last
late night show probably sometime in
june i'm guessing
um
and
where am i
i'm on the ninth floor wow in my office
and i'm watching the feed
and i'm watching dave record his last
show just uh three floors below three
floors below me and he's recording in
the studio that i'm going to take over
but we haven't even gotten started yet
and i'm sitting there watching it and so
dave does this amazing show last show
and then bruce springsteen comes out and
does glory days right
and i'm in my office watching this and
then it ends and dave does his final
words and he says i'm moving on this has
been really and he says the last thing
he says
is and uh conan o'brien i don't know
much about the man but i i believe he
shot somebody once you know which it
would always get sure and then he said
uh i hope someday he has me on his show
that'd be nice anyway good night
that ends and i'm like for the first
time as long as dave was on the air i
felt this isn't real yes once he left
suddenly it's like
you're up kid oh wait right dimaggio
just left the batter's box he just hit a
home run yeah you're up i hope you're
watching here i am
also it
feels heavy
we went down there after the show i was
going to get to that yeah and what was
surreal to me first of all they're all
there who's they joe just sprinkled
things down there they were all diabetes
no no but it's like letterman's just
done his last show so there's a whole
thing
bruce is in the hall wearing like a
flannel shirt and having a you know
literally like he had like a beer bottle
because someone had put beer out it's a
problem and um yeah it was just filled
with uh lacroix
um so
dave was in this little tiny dressing
room and someone said you should go in
there so i went in and i just
suddenly i'm in a tiny tiny room with
david letterman just done his last show
and he wishes me well and i said that
was really amazing and well i i should
go and start making the show that will
replace
your iconic show i suppose and i walk
outside and tom hanks was a guest on the
last show and tom hanks is there yeah
with his wife rita and tom looks at me
and he knew i knew him from being a
writer on snl and he you know he he used
to call
robert bob odenkirk and i the and greg
daniels the boiler room boys he'd be
like hey fellas we're the boy over
fellas get over here fellas and so he
was like he looked at me and he stared
right through me and like put his hands
on my shoulders and he said
what's just happened to you doesn't
happen wow it never happens
and
i don't know exactly how to take that
but i don't think he meant anything but
he was pretty much saying
this is kind of unprecedented in show
business history
okay i'm gonna go now
don't [ __ ] this guy
i also remember being in that hallway
and immediately they were ripping the
set out oh my god and i'm i was just
watching them rip this out and [ __ ]
on the floor pretty much
and just going and
our set experience would had a little to
be desired you know with that first set
and and we're going through all that i'm
watching this set being ripped out i'm
just like oh my god oh that's real this
is we just got to figure it out so is
empty by probably the next two days
later yeah there's a thing i think that
night thing you hear about a lot
of breaks that uh you know back before
people there were rules and laws about
child care that if you wanted to teach a
child to swim
you would just take the child and throw
him into the deep end of the pool this
was
this was like i'm taking the child into
a c-47 plane
and throwing them out into the arctic
waters and the worst thing about it all
was like i think if it had been done
to me my psychological response would
have been you know if i was told by the
government your name's been selected
randomly and you have to replace
letterman and this is your your job to
save america i would have had a very
different attitude about it but in my
own [ __ ] up catholic way i think i was
very much you asked for this [ __ ]
yeah you and so i got what you wanted i
had yeah you got what you wanted [ __ ]
now let's see you know you put yourself
in this position
you said yes because someone just had to
host a talk show and
the voice in my head is far more
punitive than anything anyone can ever
say to me and so i just beat the [ __ ]
out of myself all the time and i now
think that when i look at the audition
or the times i've seen it since i was
more relaxed in the audition
than i was on television because
psychologically well i'm being asked to
try out well i'll do my part
nothing to lose i took it very seriously
yes it just took me a while
for the volume it was literally the
volume in the amount of work we were
doing and the volume of shows
and it's getting malcolm gladwell's 10
000 hours yeah the hard way in front of
everybody in front of it in front of
everybody and so
you could probably see watch a you could
have a some program could probably take
one image three images a show
from every show the first two years and
speed them up and you would literally
see
somebody
you know
my skeletal structure would change right
from the sheer i wanted it to work i was
it was not going to not work right i
remember thinking it was
this is going to work because it has to
work because
being a joke trivia question is not an
option right yeah
but that to me just learning to do that
on the job because you you mentioned
like tina fey and
you know seth like yes they were writer
background but then they had all this
performance
experience kind of
yeah under the radar second city yeah
almost everyone in television started
you know letterman was a weather man and
even that
yeah just that little practice just
being me in front of a camera just being
yeah right to be fair
i used to go to uh department stores a
lot that were selling televisions
and they used to have a video camera
and i would do the thing right
i swear to god i i i i had spent a lot
of time impressed yeah i had really
taken it back really gotten my chops
floor five yeah it is a very improbable
story and and that's where it ended for
you too and that's why no
no but you know that's so funny that's
amazing what's crazy to me is that's the
beginning yeah and
we've told you
1 20th of the good stuff because there's
so much insanity that happened and we're
saving that for the book
but
that's just the beginning yeah and you
could believe like and then finally the
ship write it itself and went off to
have a pleasant career we haven't gotten
to the tonight show like yeah that is
in every way as insane and unprecedented
and crazy and
counterintuitive
as the beginning yes and that happens 16
years later
what's fascinating is we told this part
of the story and then you i go i was
about to say well and then we went up
those elevators in the coolest building
that you could do television in in the
world for the next 16 years yeah
it's crazy yeah yeah the volume of stuff
and the the variety of things that we
tried
i can't even
i see it now and i have no connection to
it so
i mean we used to do a piece
where
we would
do a whole like soap opera
in front of the audience
and with
famous people john lithgow did it john
lithgow did it and martin sheen did it
and we would have people in the audience
wear a green
like sock a green screen green screen
over their head so that we could drop
them in and put their heads on the
bodies of actors who were there so that
an audience member who just showed up
and paul was looking at me horrified
yeah paula davis is here
stay in your seat
it was called
paula davis one of the first people we
hired to be our booker and she's sitting
here and
paula you don't even remember this you
booked it you booked she didn't know you
hosted it yeah i'm conan by the way
um she's like where's corden i'm like
okay we'll get to that his american
accent is impressive there are maybe 75
to 100
sketches or more right that someone
could tell me we did
and i would say
don't do that
how would that even work it was putting
out a newspaper
every day and there was no you could
never not move the clock back and then
and then in the middle of that somebody
says
let's do the show on the circle line
right okay yeah yeah let's get a circle
line right well a circle line bow yeah
for the the boats that go around
manhattan but i mean that's i have to
say
robert gets a lot of credit for robert
has
large eyes like there's that old saying
my grandmother used to say if you didn't
finish your food she'd say well your
eyes were bigger than your stomach right
yeah and robert has creatively huge eyes
like i
let's rent a zeppelin yes let's fill it
with cheddar cheese let's get paula to
book and he makes it happen yeah and
let's get
he wills it through an insane you know
and and
things get crazy and hairy and there are
fist fights and there's shouting maybe
people get killed during the sketch who
knows
but um they're not important when we
were really taking heat early on right
not in through 93 and people are um
i was reading at the time there were
reviews that said things like it would
be really nice if you know conan died
you know and it'd be great if andy died
with him
you know just just people were just very
upset by it and uh
that's actually in print i think once
your home town paper yeah yeah
you're fine exactly i was gonna say
written by dr thomas o'brien
um
if he died it wouldn't be his fault you
see he never adequately explained jeff
ross to me yeah just now and now he must
be punished there was there was a time
when
um i think
even lauren was saying couldn't you just
interview people and couldn't it be
because because our comedy was very
aggressive right and aggressively
strange and i think still looks that way
and they thought well this conan guy he
cleans up nice and he's affable right
why can't he just be affable and chat
with people and that way they're still
the problems there's less sticky edges
instead um you know conan's yodeling and
he's wearing a bikini and andy's dressed
as a monkey and the whole thing is
uh very there's a punk rock element to
it like like it or go [ __ ] yourself one
of the great things about that when you
wound up your show in tbs last year were
all these
successful like seth rogen and all these
other big names who you wouldn't this
wouldn't even occur to you at the time
we're just trying to do a show every
night yeah they all
they all ate the feast of all this
comedy yeah we're like finally someone's
making comedy for me and that's what
people felt that must have been very
satisfying it was but i have to say
i don't know how you felt jeff but i
think the thing that gratifies me the
most is that
you know haters and mullaney's and all
these these people who are
so
um crazy talented and good at what they
do and brilliant and um they say nice
things about and and what our show meant
to them back in the day and my immediate
response is couldn't you have said
anything
because because nothing you're old
enough to write yeah like couldn't you
have written something why weren't you
annoying mr o'brien did fairness that it
would there were a couple of situations
where somebody's kids yes they were they
were hearing like executives who i can't
remember who it was who was it there was
a guy who um and again this is probably
for another installment but there was a
guy who was sort of hired to kick us in
the ass and he was uh had worked with
don ohmeyer and his job was to come and
kick us in the ass and you know let's
let's let's get this thing moving again
i mean we got to figure this out and you
know knock off all this [ __ ] you
guys are [ __ ] this up and so it was
like an episode of a sitcom where wow
character comes in a drill sergeant
moves in with the family oh boy does he
turn things upside down
but i remember him telling us you got to
pull this together
then he went off to visit his i believe
it was his son who went to boston
college so he went and went to visit his
son and he was hanging out in the dorm
room and he's like so guys you know you
know tell me what is everybody watching
these days what are the kids loving and
he said the dorm room was like conan wow
and he was saying no no seriously
seriously seriously you know did you
guys like jazz
on its way out yeah you guys like
caroline in the city right and they were
like
no no it's we watch conan it's so great
and weird and to his credit he did
repeat that he told me he didn't have to
tell me but he told me um well he's got
to take credit for it i mean in the end
that's probably the kind of thing that
saved us yes yes i mean the first thing
that saved us was nobody was paying
attention we could do whatever we wanted
right yeah and then it became after the
initial yeah
i think what helped save us
is that we were in new york
and
had we been in los angeles where they
could come in if we had been in los
angeles they could have been there every
day and they would have seen me putting
on an octopus costume right right and us
putting a green felt sock over martin
sheen's head
and uh and they would have said stop we
just saw that on the field stop
have dick caved on and interview him and
be pleasant to you [ __ ] and we
were a car accident so there was also a
bit of a
let's not take that road that i mean
people stayed away from us for a while
because no one wanted
to own it and we we have to give a shout
out to
someone who was a real stalwart uh rick
ludwig who is no longer with us rick
ledwin uh was
the nbc executive in charge of late
night
and he was horrified by a lot that we
were doing early on yeah but
he was there and he was watching
audiences laugh at us he was the first
executive to get it yes yeah and
and had the only one with the balls to
go into a room and go
it's good he said he said i don't get it
he said
he said something's happening here you
know there's something happening here
what it is ain't exactly clear you can
edit that out or actually put music into
lupus there's something
over there
i've got to be well it's time to stop
don't make that show everybody says my
favorite stew gizmo anyway
this is why i really thought you know
what if i had said if my al hadn't come
along
if i had if i had sung that diddy at my
rehearsal you wouldn't know me now
i'd be at the guy at ikea i know
there was a divine force helping you
through helping me not make stupid songs
up yeah rick ludwin said there's
something happening there and he just
doubled down and went to bat for us and
uh what remained a good friend of us all
through you know everything and even
through the tonight show craziness was
like nope
disagreed with people audibly
anyway not important um
yeah we have to uh wrap this up we do
have to wrap this up so
just look up the tomatoes
the serious deal people can read about
that online well this was a new spin-off
series
this
it's tough and i know i run off at the
mouth but it's very outside i i'm very
i don't talk about this stuff a lot and
so when it comes up
in this forum you realize it's like ptsd
right you start talking and it's it's
hard to stop no no it just it felt very
visceral like you were there and you
were remembering the lucite table and it
was nice seeing all this it's also
easier to talk to you guys about it
because you know what it is right yeah
but also
the process of talking about it it's
almost like
to reaffirm that it really happened
because it was so yeah well that's why i
will say i'm i'm grateful to you guys
for doing this podcast because
um as much as i
uh i have trouble listening to
our podcast
just the i like the
sense that you exist and are doing and
sharing it with me
it's just a lack of chemistry
uh let's get a robot and a bottle of
soap
i'll have you know no no no i hope i'm
the soap oh you are definitely i love
being a robot but bleep bleep where's my
oil uh you know the joint i have trouble
going back there sometimes i mean i have
trouble going back and and
but um the fact that you guys are
talking to robert and bill toe and when
i heard that you guys had done a deep
dive on the old-timey baseball remote
and found
nell
is it now yes yes she hasn't forgotten
you and and found her that is a magical
moment in my life and this is very
name-droppy but we just paul and i went
and saw
jack white do his show recently
and he was telling me afterwards we both
realized we're going to be in the
seattle area on the same time and he
said oh i'm i'm playing a baseball game
then with a bunch of friends and i'm
going to be in there because he's on
tour and he said you should stop by and
uh and uh you could do you could you
could play with us he said and you could
do it as an old-timey guy and then he's
like quoting from it and i'm realizing
he probably saw that when he was like
eight why didn't he write a letter
exactly what got him into comedy i'm
really grateful that you guys are doing
this because you know you can love us
you can hate us but whatever happened
during this crazy 28 29 year span
was
authentic
kooky and involved a lot of brilliant
weird difficult
lovable people
you know in this movable feast that just
seems to i mean now it's continuing in
audio form and and i think we'll morph
into other things but i just love that
you guys are are getting these stories
down because
none of us should have ever been allowed
to be in rockford center or warner
brothers or any of these places it's
insane and i love that you're getting
this sort of oral history of a terrible
mistake right